I think one of the most underrated
skills for learning history is learning
how to think like a historian and what
do I mean by thinking like a historian
does that mean that you have to go out
and buy a tweed jacket with some elbow
patches and maybe grow a long white
beard and sit around all day pondering
whether the Civil War was caused by
slavery or states rights no but you can
try that if you want but I would say
thinking like a historian is a little
bit like being a combination between a
storyteller and a scientist are you
going to see me draw a really really bad
beaker here there we go some little fans
coming off of that and a lawyer maybe
I'll put a gavel here it's a gavel not a
croquet mallet or hammer so first let's
start with a storytelling aspect I think
one of the most important things that we
can learn from telling this story of
history is that in a good story nothing
just happens right right
imagine a story where everything just
happened the story would be the wind
blows the earth turns right no one is
making those things happen and that's
why it's kind of a boring story because
it doesn't show cause and effect and
that cause and effect is really the
backbone of history right and you would
be surprised how often people can fall
into the trap of telling history this
incredible story about what people have
done in the past that has led to the
society we have to
a as if it were kind of a laundry list
of events that just followed one after
another without any possibility of
things being different people will say
and then World War two happened or and
then the United States was born right
those statements are in passive voice
because they don't talk about the people
who make these things happen and really
short of a natural disaster
pretty much everything happens in
history because people made it happen so
when you think like a historian you kind
of think the same way that a novelist
might think okay what is this
character's motive what are they going
to do to make their wish come true what
are the influences that lead a person to
make certain choices and just like
people make choices nations make choices
right World War one didn't just happen
and just as people make choices actions
have consequences you wouldn't write a
story where a thief stole a hundred
million dollars and the police didn't
even try to come after her neither can
you write a story about history without
talking about the effects that actions
have on people so that's the
storytelling aspect of thinking like a
historian let's talk about the
scientific aspect we often think of
history as something that's it's pretty
much done right it's a series of events
that happened in the past and now we
just have to memorize what happened so
we can learn from it and maybe have a
good idea about what to do in the future
but really there's only so much we can
actually know about what happened in the
past and so historians always have to do
a kind of research to understand what
happened and get a better idea of what
people were feeling so just like
scientists have theories when historians
think about the past they're really
thinking about theories as well they're
saying okay I have a theory about
what caused the evolution of jazz in the
1920s why did jazz become a major
popular form of music in the 1920s well
I'm going to theorize it was because
people were reacting to the horror of
World War one which made so many people
interested in kind of staccato notes and
discordant sounds all right so that's a
theory well how do you go about proving
a theory and the answer is you do
research and you consult evidence right
and the way that you do that in history
is usually by doing a lot of reading
right you might say all right well let
me take the letters of some jazz
musicians from this time period and see
what they write about maybe they write
all about how they experienced battle in
World War one and they were trying to
reflect that in their music or maybe
they write that World War One had
nothing to do with their interest in
music actually they wanted to simulate
the sounds of flight because they were
so interested in modern forms of
transportation so our understanding of
what happened in the past is always just
a theory I mean we have a pretty good
idea of what was going on most of the
time but new information comes to light
all the time right
I mean people are always cleaning out
their grandma's attic and finding some
new documents and as the preponderance
of the evidence shifts and changes so
might our understanding of the past the
last aspect of thinking like a historian
I want to talk about is this kind of
lawyerly aspect and what I mean by this
is that historians are always making an
argument
just like a lawyer gets up in a
courtroom and says here's my idea now
let me support it with the evidence from
witnesses from experts from objects that
we might have found at a crime scene a
historian is saying believe my theory
believe my evidence and I think the
analogy of law is really powerful here
because you could see the same pieces of
evidence used to support two different
arguments so for example say there's
maybe a sock that was found at the scene
of a crime right here's our sock I am
NOT a beautiful artist but maybe the
prosecution tries to argue that the
accused must have committed this crime
because the sock is his size all right
the sock shows he did it whereas the
defense might say my client never wears
socks he always wears sandals so it's
clear that the sock shows that he
couldn't possibly have been the one to
do this crime so that's how we end up
with so many different interpretations
of the same event the task of the
historian is to gather evidence and to
present an argument that they think will
best convince the public of their
interpretation and so these
interpretations do change over time so
in later videos we'll get into the nuts
and bolts of how you tell these stories
and make these arguments but for now I
just kind of want you to see that
thinking like a historian is not
something that only historians can do
it's actually a really useful skill for
lots of aspects of your life we tell
stories search for evidence and make
arguments in our lives all the time
about things that we interact with every
day like
our favorite bands our favorite foods
our political views right we base those
on our own experiences consequences in
our lives and evidence that we see
around us and we can do the same thing
for the past it's not such a foreign
country what we have are the remnants of
that past and the ability to interpret
them